Протести є, а Майдану - немає.
Акція, очолювана "Рухом нових сил" Міхеіла Саакашвілі
вже котрий день поспіль блокує центр Києва.
Вже були і сутички з поліцією, і ультиматум владі.
Під Верховною Радою стоять намети.
Проте відчуття того, що акція стала народною
і ось-ось переросте в революцію
чи новий Майдан - немає.
І перехожі на Майдані Незалежності - приєднуватися не поспішають.
Мабуть, у них різні вимоги і підходи.
Швидше за все.
А потім, вони наче об'єднані, але все-одно кожен сам по собі.
Так, ціль хороша.
Мабуть, багато лідерів, не можуть ніяк домовитися.
Це зараз зовсім не потрібно.
І протести.. це все..
Нічого з того не буде, це не революція, народ не підтримує,
кияни не підтримують, нічого не буде.
Соціологи вбачають кілька причин того, що ці акції протесту
не користуються масовою підтримкою українців.
По-перше, вимог кілька і з них достатньо чітке гасло
тільки зняття депутатської недоторканності.
Для чого новий закон про вибори та антикорупційний суд,
українцям ще не так добре відомо.
По-друге, ці проблеми не є найактуальнішими.
І на завершення - такої політичної сили,
яка б могла вивести українців на масовий протест - зараз немає.
У нас тільки 30% населення каже,
що буцімто є якісь політичні сили,
нехай і не консолідовані, які можуть щось змінити.
А 70% кажуть, що немає таких сил.
А ці 70% думають так:
краще нехай буде якісь
два-три-чотири сильних лідери,
але аби вони діяли в інтересах народу,
бо політичним силам ніхто не вірить.
Хоча протестний потенціал в Україні загалом великий.
Як показує опитування Інституту імені Яременка,
проведене на початку вересня,
понад 29 відсотків населення вважають імовірними масові виступи
людей на захист своїх прав.
А 23 відсотки - готові особисто до них долучитися.
Це більше, ніж було три роки тому.
Водночас бажання брати участь у мітингах,
організованих якоюсь політичної силою
дедалі менше й менше.
За даними фонду "Демократичні ініціативи",
ще три роки тому, під час Революції гідності,
Віталію Кличку довіряла майже половина населення,
Арсенію Яценюку - 45 відсотків,
а Петру Порошенку - 43 відсотки.
Зараз політики можуть лише мріяти про такі симпатії.
Найпопулярніша нині "Батьківщина" Юлії Тимошенко
у неї 11 відсотків підтримки.
Це показує величезне падіння довіри до лідерів опозиції.
Протистояння, яке ми бачимо сьогодні в парламенті,
яке ми бачимо сьогодні на вулиці,
воно стимульоване боротьбою різних олігархічних кланів,
тобто боротьбою багатих і багатих
з використанням тих бідних,
які мають певну надію
Водночас ситуацією не варто зовсім легковажити.
Участь у протестах беруть впливові партії,
а радикальних активістів серед мітингарів - сотні.
Порівняно з попередніми Майданами, небезпека провокування насильства
та силових дій - значно вища.